welcome back to new rock stars and
daredevil has been born again in the mcu
with a new green best friend and fresh
new red and yellow digs i love it i love
the original look but what if i told you
that the title born again isn't just a
reference to matt murdock's catholic
roots what if i told you that the
netflix daredevil was reborn into the
mcu how would that make you feel this is
rogue theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
rogue with me today is the wit without
fear it's whitney van landingham what's
going on with me hi
i'm good
not a lot going on what's up with you
guys
we just hanging out
we gotta go
um and the jewel of new rockstars our
very own private investigator it's
off-screen producer brandon hello
brandon how do you do that hello mt and
were you insinuating that frogman and
daredevil are best friends um i would
say she-hulk but uh yes i thought the
green the green person you were
referring to was frogman i know this was
mine i totally thought it was frogman
too i did not know
you know uh frogman and daredevil will
fight uh it'll be a very bloody fight in
uh at the very end of the she-hulk
season so uh looking forward to that one
confirmed confirmed and finally it's the
fist of the dragon himself the immortal
tom michelson everybody hey everybody
let me show you my shout out tattoo hold
on a sec
again thanks for having me i know i just
any chance i can to just take my shirt
off i do it but these guys are on to me
so sorry i'm sorry
for the last eight times tom you know
i'm like you're starting to pick up on
your trip
exactly
how was the flight from kunlun oh that
was a nice safe place it's great yeah
they had drinks they don't serve meals
anymore which sucks but you know we got
pretzels and little snacks so great
otherwise
you're right on a dragon yeah yeah
exactly yes i've never had a story the
whole time i'm just like yeah
riding the whole way here yeah exactly
i freaking love uh falcore yeah wait did
he die no falco didn't die did falcor
die he's dead to me anyway
he's dead to me
he knows what he did
but all right guys let's talk about our
first topic of today daredevil because i
think i think
that the netflix daredevil swap places
with the mcu matt murdock during the
snap and the blip era and here's why i
think that i think that because that
marvel studios now has the rights to
these marvel and to these marvel netflix
characters like your daredevils your
your iron fists your jessica jones your
luke cages i think that since they have
legally taken them out of netflix and
taken bringing them to the mcu i think
that they're also going to symbolically
do that within the mcu itself with the
snap i think that the actual mcu
versions of matt murdock and jessica
jones used to exist in the mcu and then
they got snapped away and then were
replaced by the netflix universe
versions of those characters when they
came back during the blip and so i think
that this is why the title daredevil
born again is born again in the mcu and
why the jessica jones on disney plus got
changed to aka jessica jones it's like
not they changed the title to aka
jessica jones um to sort of like
insinuate that like this is also jessica
jones but not
actual like mcu jessica jones because
like they switch places and there's a
different universe like it's it's weird
um so yeah this is what i think i think
that this netflix daredevil is just
filling in for his mcu counterpart
because
thanos messed things up and hulk
did some weird things during the snap
hulk snapped he's all like everyone back
don't change anything and also the
netflix shows snap
she's like awesome
[Laughter]
oh man what do you guys think about this
you guys think it's
rogues i don't know what do you guys
think so you think there were so there
was in the mcu okay it's it's it's uh uh
20 2018 mcu
there's a matt murdock walking around
not necessarily charlie cox could be
could look completely different well
let's say he looks like exactly
uh but does he have powers or is this a
guy named matt murdock
uh and he's like unpowered um either way
it could be powered or unpowered i think
that a matt murdock existed in the mcu
and was replaced by a variant who okay
is the netflix daredevil that has the
same experiences as the netflix show
um so like either way like i think that
would be great if like the daredevil was
running around but like it doesn't seem
like the people
are all that familiar with daredevil
yeah yeah yeah and we haven't heard any
anything of daredevil yet um so like it
just seems like he's new so i feel like
this matt murdock was probably just
chilling as a lawyer regular guy um and
then he was blipped away and then here
comes daredevil just like a regular
dog yeah he came to work on monday it's
like mad are you blind
what happened dude and it's like well
it's like oh yeah i don't know something
something weird happened
i've been blind all my life
you're not a lawyer we clean sewers for
a living oh
baby what are you doing
oh my goodness
what do you guys think about this like
you think it's too weird because like i
feel like because the mcu is going
towards this multiverse route we know
that this is the multiverse saga we in
it baby it's all about kang and all the
timelines and everything so like
i feel like variants are going to i have
to factor into like a title like born
again yeah i mean it it does make sense
i
i i mean i'm still really really holding
out that we're just gonna get a super
christian version
i'm just really hoping that we're gonna
put the christ back in christmas baby
christ back in christmas with matt
murdock this year that's what i'm hoping
oh my goodness he came back from the
blip and now he believes
let's have a daredevil christmas episode
where it's just heavily
christian christmas
cameron and
yeah matt murdock's just like visiting
starbucks being like why does it say
christmas on your cups
[Laughter]
yeah he's checking out the nativity
scenes and he's like the wise man didn't
show up for three years get him out of
here
he's like super buy the book he wants
everything right
where's my black jesus
oh man i'm just gonna say i really like
a lot of what you're saying mt because
um
you know i hadn't really thought of it
that way but having having it be a
variant type situation would be the most
perfect uh out for them because then
they could have charlie cox who everyone
loves his daredevil and then maybe sorry
finn jones if they want a new iron fist
they don't have to you know they don't
have they're not committed to bringing
him back
nice guy i'm sure the show
that way we're not committed to the
netflix verse but we can have the best
parts if we want like we can have you
know mike coulter if we wanted we could
have you know charlie cox and of course
vincent d'onofrio and then you know
maybe even jessica jones and then that
we can have um uh you know purple men
back i don't know you could pick and
choose what you want i i kind of like
that um
there's some good there's some good
parts to that actually i really liked
how they could explain away some of
these things yeah i actually do think
that kingpin himself was brought back
from the snap from the netflix universe
and he just got them both i thought that
things were different and like i i don't
really know what's going on my variant
lived a different life and uh i guess
i'm not doing too well so i got to work
my way back up to the top um and so i
don't know it just feels
if it doesn't feel like it's right then
it was definitely the morby verse where
uh through doctor strange some people
ended up in our universe for some reason
like these two
for
oh it's just like oh my god the whole
mcu is now the morbius plants that would
be hilarious
we're just living in it
it's moving time all the time
it's morbid time all the time
all the freaking time oh i was going to
say empty i do like this idea of like
the switch happening during the blip and
like maybe some of them but not all of
them
like if uh you know daredevil is like he
seeks out jessica jones and she also got
switched and they're like yeah yeah i
know you i know you but they go and find
like luke cage and he's like i don't
know how you people at all how did you
know about my brother it's like that
kind of thing like maybe our the mcu's
luke cage is like really in hiding or
something and it's like really afraid
and they come and find him he's like i
don't know you guys so it's like not the
whole defender's gun right over uh just
like so i'm like i would love it i like
that idea yeah it'd be really fun and
like yo if the fcu is gonna cast a new
lou cage we should go laz alonso from
the boys i'm just saying he's great
he's really really cool
like phenomenal um but no my culture was
fantastic as well but like yeah no i
would love for like a little a mishmash
of like all right netflix like the best
of netflix and like you know maybe some
new uh new luke cage or a new iron fist
like that'd be really cool um
because we don't want to see origin
stories again necessarily especially if
disney has the rights to these shows now
which are all origin stories
right yes they i'm going to call them
all origin stories because they even if
it's in flashback in later episodes
they're origin stories yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can just go watch those you
don't need to restart i don't need to
see
baby matt murdock get splashed with
chemicals again i get it we get it it's
done
daredevil got his powers he went into
that spaceship got hit by cosmic rays
yeah
shop was blind
oh my god
machine
i think you can't that's what he wanted
that's what he wanted that's how he made
it
it's his wish actually we're
this sort of is within matt murdock's
character in the comments because one
time he uh what uh moon dragon made him
unblind and then he asked her to make
him blind again because he's like i'm
not as good of a fighter
because i can see he's fair yeah his
powers are like
10 billion times better because wait
would he have supersite if he no i guess
not because you are undocumented because
of the
his other sentences are augmented
because he's blind but if he got his
sight back he has super sight like x-ray
vision heat vision i don't know i don't
think maybe
everything just be way too [ __ ] loud
for him if he got his sight back he'd
all of a sudden just be like god damn it
i would be napping 24 7. i'd be like
there's too much world stimuli i'm i'm
not oh yeah oh you have to just
24 7. and i will say i mean if i
suddenly
i love the netflix series but and born
again in these 18 episodes of born again
i do not want a single scene where matt
murdock is getting like too much
information and it's been done
please
please that is like the trope of tropes
like your power is not working or
whatever and you're getting too much
again it's like
that it's like we get to focus match
yeah yeah once again to focus
but no i feel like a scenario like like
a multiverse swapping does open up the
opportunity for via an mcu daredevil and
a netflix daredevil to potentially team
up during a secret war scenario if there
was a daredevil before the snap yeah
i just feel like it'd be really great
like defenders team up it's like hey
let's get all eight defenders together
and uh to to fight in secret wars
because that'd be really cool
i like this idea
it makes me think too i love this idea
of like the power of the snap and what
it did like with the born again title
what if like mcu's matt murdock he's
daredevil he's fighting a criminal or
kingpin or something and like he dies
uncharacteristic of it like like
very uncharistic and characteristic
right he died
the mcu matt murdock dies like maybe
five minutes before thanos snap right
he's like fighting like how we saw like
elena about to kill that woman and then
everything changed like he died like
he's been stabbed he's like
froggy
and he's like
yeah my best friend frog man is my best
friend
foggy and froggy my two best friends
you're finally both here if i had two
more wishes i'd wish for you again
[Laughter]
you know
and it's just like a minute before the
snap or whatever and when hulk does is
like bring back he accidentally grabs
like dead matt murdoch from hell because
let's face it matt murdock's going to
hell baby he's going straight down
rips him out and so like matt murdock
literally dies but then is brought back
to life from the snap so and maybe
there's like messed up parts of that
where he can remember dying or something
weird like that or he remembers the
afterlife
isn't that kind of precedent for that
and in the comics isn't that how hawkeye
came back when uh wanda we made reality
because hawkeye was dead at that point
and then when she after house of m
he was just back when the because he's
like i was supposed to be dead and that
really wasn't
you know avengers disassembled i think
uh disassembled and then when she
brought reality back he was just back
and that really kind of messed around
yeah that's comics baby
he was like i'm gonna hunt her down and
make her kill me again because i did not
walk
right
like that yeah i think you're awesome i
mean they they brought back jason todd
they can bring back anybody thank you
right anybody oh yeah for sure for sure
for sure like purple man i feel like
purple man is gonna come back like one
of the most menacing like one of the
most terrifying villains
is welcome but he definitely went too
soon like kilgrave was like right but
like hey
you gotta get rid of him you gotta get
rid of him
i want him to [ __ ] die because he's a
piece of [ __ ] but he's also an amazing
villain because i want him to stand
exactly but like hey since like this is
a new universe from the separate netflix
universe we have a new potential purple
man it's like if the purple men didn't
get strapped we could still have the
purple man ready to be made in the mcu
so like we could get dave attended back
it'd be really fun if they if they did
this round of switching multiverse
variants with uh the difference yeah
it's really cool i would love to get
david tennant back so good like one of
the best actors of our time
david tennant my dude so good
love you guys
anyway
adopt me daddy literally i've been a fan
of doctor who for too long so david
tennant if you want to adopt a 30 year
old black man
hit me out anytime
just write in the comments
below us know
in the comments
i'll see it the real david please
respond if you'd like to become a daddy
to any of the people please let us know
in the comments below the t stands for
tenants
all right guys so time for our voting
time do you think this theory of
daredevil being a netflix variant um in
the mcu universe as rogus
bogus or ogus
take it away brandon i'll i'll go rogus
i like this idea i really like this the
old switcheroo
i think that would be fun and it would
it's a fun way to bring some not
everyone perfect love it all right thank
you all right what do you think some not
everyone we don't want the party to be
too full
as long as colleen wing and turk barrett
are here that's all i care about really
oh yeah
what do you think whitney oh man i'm
also going to give this a rogues i do
really like this idea and damn tom you
really like you you you clinched that
for me with reminding me of hawkeye and
house of them because yeah no they
totally
what what does marvel do if not pull
very random
threads from old comics and make that
their entire personality for the next
phase
[Music]
so yeah i know i i love this idea i
think that that's i think that that'd be
really cool i'm interested to see what
their like science explanation for it is
you know because like obviously there's
like the it's just magic and superheroes
that's how it works kid shut up and
give me your money but like i do want to
see if like hulk has like oh this is why
when this happened during the snap this
is the scientific reason that this
person had to come back like i would
kill to see that kind of stuff in
she-hulk that would be awesome i would
love that so just having like because
like if she runs into matt murdock and
they're like wait how are you here wait
how are you here
and then like bruce helps them figure
out how that there's one whole episode
of the shark to be reborn
i
[Laughter]
that sounds great bruce is the best
person to do it because he's now the
foremost expert on the multiverse sort
of other than you know i guess the pen
yeah kinda yeah ever since tony left
she's like all right it's just me now
so i know
he's satisfied
on a vacation he sacrificed his life
he was sleepy
what do you think tom
i i'm gonna i'm gonna go rogue on this
and say ogus only because i like it
i like it i think i'm just missing uh
but it's funny because i'm i'm going
ogus because of what whitney said too
which is i'm missing a few details that
i want to hear and find out more about
like was it the stones was it the snap
and and and and has have the stones
affected the multiverse before because
wasn't there in loki the they showed the
stones don't really do anything outside
of their own universe
so it's like they're just
interesting yeah is it not and so uh is
it the more verse i need to i know it is
the verse
in this empty it would have been two two
two thumbs up but no i i like it i
really like a lot of it i'm just missing
the the few i just missing that one up
of she-hulk where they go over the chart
but when that comes out oh i'll be here
okay i'll take two rogues isn't an ogus
that sounds like the name of a sitcom
two rogues is
[Laughter]
it's the sad um
but up next brandon has a really
interesting theory about kang and his
connection to doctor doom but first head
on over to newrockstarsmerch.com to grab
our newest latest obsession shirt worthy
of love inspired by thor love and
thunder it's limited edition and once
it's sold out it's gone forever so you
don't want to miss out if you have fomo
here's me triggering your fomo so check
out the shirt and all of our amazing
merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com it's a great way to
support the channel and all the work
that we do here and we love you guys but
either way if you don't do it we still
love you this episode is brought to you
by bluetooth because summer is here and
the temperature isn't the only thing
that's rising
blue chew can help you give that extra
bit of confidence in the bedroom blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and you
can take them any time day or night so
you can plan ahead or be ready whenever
the opportunity arises in that i know
that opportunities arise for all of our
new rockstars fans all the time because
let's face it you guys bang uh the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of our
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations about donors and stuff and
no waiting in line at the pharmacy blue
chew tablets are made in the usa and
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discreet package so if you want to
help make this summer a summer of love
give yourself that boost of confidence
and head on over to bluechew.com and
we've got a special day for all
listeners try bluetooth free when use
our promo code rogue at checkout just
pay five dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free so visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bleachy for sponsoring this video
and podcast and we want to thank faraday
for sponsoring rogue theory there is so
much to do this summer and whether
you're spending long sunny days by the
pool or by the patio like
whitney or just exploring the country on
patio if you're a patio [ __ ] like me
yeah get it
exploring the country on road trips or
even just seeing how many movies you can
watch at the cinema in a single week
we're all striving to make this summer
the best summer ever and faraday makes
the perfect close for the summer their
collection of high quality clothing is
incredibly soft and comfortable and
always sustainably minded and meant to
be worn from surf to city to cineplex
verity is a family-run brand making
high-quality timeless clothing with
modern design and functionality they've
mastered the art of the perfect summer
fit every last style that makes you look
good super comfortable clothes that have
been designed with intention their style
looks like it might be vintage but it
fits so well then it feels like it was
made just yesterday and made just for
you that's what ferrari does best
several of the staff members here at new
rockstars love their verity clothes you
can find off-screen producer zack
grilling up some burgers this summer in
his legend sweater shirt he loves the
comfort and style that comes with
ferrari their clothes are thoughtfully
crafted with a classic style and you
will wear them over and over again and
ferrari is so committed to
sustainability that they even have a
lifetime guarantee of quality they'll
replace or fix your clothes forever no
matter what no matter what so your
clothes can last as long as your
favorite summertime memories and right
now faraday is giving all rogue theory
fans 20
off let me say that again 20
off head to faritybrand.com slash rogue
and use code rogue at checkout to get
this deal that's code rogue at fahrity
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand.com rogue for twenty
percent off veritybrand.com
rogue all right gang it's time for our
second topic and brandon is going to
lead us in it let's let's hear it
brandon okay okay so we all know that
the fantastic four are coming blah blah
blah blah blah
[Laughter]
one scene where ben graham's like i
don't want to be a rock man anymore you
gotta put it in a fantastic four movie
it's gotta look like so uh yeah
but
we're gonna get doctor doom it's gotta
happen they can't they gotta give us
doom at some point but here's here's
where we're going to get rugged with
doom okay
doom is not going to be the doom we know
and love marvel's going to throw a
little curveball doom is going to be a
kang okay and how
this kang is going to get here i don't
think the mc doom is the mcu does not
have that variant it does not exist in
the mcu uh it's not there they're not
gonna be like oh this other hidden
country that's technologically advanced
they're done doing that no more of that
okay uh what's gonna happen is with all
this multiversal stuff that's going on
there's gonna be some weird thing where
like these refugees show up from another
earth that was destroyed okay and and
from that earth they are light variants
that was the name of the country from
the earth they came from that is
destroyed uh and they're being led by
their late their leader victor von doom
uh that will all be true he he used his
technological and magical prowess to
open up a portal to save his people
before their earth was destroyed in an
incursion or something like that uh but
that victor von doom that's gonna be
leading them that's gonna come over is
gonna be revealed to be a kang and this
was all like part of his this kang's
plan to get into our universe because we
know that he who remains was scripting
things to keep the kangs out this is
gonna be one of many kangs and he's
gonna be a doom uh and he's gonna come
over and they're gonna wrap up doom and
kang in one tasty
little morsel
won't look like jonathan majors he will
look different uh okay most of the kings
are gonna look like jonathan majors but
that'll be the reveal later uh because
we'll see that he looks different we're
all gonna be it's dr doom they gotta
worry about doctor doom but you gotta
worry about doom and king boom double
punch
i love this a lot consider especially
considering like at the beginning of
like hangs like marvel uh appearances he
thought that he was related to doctor
doom if i'm not mistaken and he was like
they did think was it one or the was it
kang thought he was a doom or doom
thought he was a king i don't remember
there is like a moment though when the
two of them interact were king
this was like when there was like ramat
or whatever and like kang doctor jim
goes back in time and he interacts with
a kang doesn't he and the kang is like
get the hell out you're not a kang or
something like that i think you were
right where doom thought he was a kang i
i think that kang went back in time to
like the modern time and there was like
hey i think that you're my ancestor or
something and like i sort of want to be
like you and so i think that's when he
adopts the scarlet centurion look and so
he sort of looks like doctor doom but
like he he's not really because he i
think you just thought that dr doom was
his uh ancestor um but yeah no i either
went there i feel like
yeah
crazy people but either way i love i
love this idea of like
a doctor doom being a king because kang
is coming to wreck up the timeline and
kang loves conquering and doctor doom
loves him at conquering as well so like
i feel like that connection is is really
good yeah
well i just if there's one thing king
loves conquering one thing doom loves do
doing conquering things
exactly because i don't think there
could be a latin area in the mcu right
now
that is the liberia we
already had sokovia and wakanda and now
we're going to get in uh what do you
call it why am i blanking on it atlantis
that's what i yeah that's we're all
afraid to say that we don't know how
this
too i is i read it but i did
if like if latveria was a variant of
sokovia from another universe and like
he brought in like brandon said he
brings down his variations that would be
a latveria over to the mcu it's like all
right here's another second but a
different one
and then the explanation for that is
whatever the answer is to
how did matt murdock get here from the
snap exactly
[Laughter]
yeah yeah hulk was just like okay bring
back everyone don't change anything for
the last five years also give me 18
episodes of uh daredevil i'm running
back charlie accidental
[Laughter]
right before he snaps
like hey could you do this like do this
real quick with your wish as well it's
like oh no problem kevin
um and then the fox got bottled up
yeah you know i i really i really like
this uh idea too it's kind of um it
would be a fun little twist and maybe it
could even be like uh
um you know a reveal for doom too that
maybe he doesn't even know he's a kang
very in some way like that would be fun
arriving and coming and doing his own
thing and then finding out uh not to not
to spoil anything for the boys but not
but having a twist to be like wait what
and having him think their enemies but
then realize that maybe they're
friends
um that would be really that would be
really cool i really like that idea a
lot because yeah i would explain it
would it would go a lot to explain why
we haven't seen doom someone so powerful
and big in the mcu just like they're
going to have to explain why the x-men
have just been awol this whole time
something's weird and a difference got
to happen same with those the fantastic
four and so yeah with doom not being
around that would be a really fun way to
tie it up all together and make it seem
like they had a plan since day one to
buy
by fox
20 years after x-men movies right oh man
how may i
i get really mad when i hear people
being like victor von doom is the
dumbest name for a villain because it
doesn't even sound like a real name uh
[ __ ] whitney van landingham
sounds about as realistic as victor von
doom okay
so i really like his name yeah i'm
really excited and like jean-paul valdez
i'm john
yeah exactly it's like there's a lesson
let us people with weird little names my
name is mt like what names are just
sounds okay
there's a nascar driver named dick
trickle i mean anything is possible okay
i don't think it's possible anything is
people he chose
richard he just chose the dick straight
for the dick hey you got to go for it
you got to go for it he chose the dick i
think that at that point your whole life
you got to leave your choices
people are going to be laughing at you
it's actually fun fact it was trequel
but he just gave
[Laughter]
name you guys yes
it's real and it's cool
i know i presented this theory and i do
like it the only thing that holds me up
is one of my favorite little factoids
about dr doom is that like his mom his
mom made a deal with mephisto and it
goes bad uh and she winds up like in
hell and like that's his whole reason
for getting into like magic and like
dimensional travel and stuff because
he's like i gotta go get my mom out of
hell uh and i i just kind of like
for like a character like he's like
that's his whole purpose like there's
this whole sequence where uh because you
you have to uh they have tournaments to
determine the source of supreme in the
comic books and one time like dr doomy
gets pretty far in the tournament and he
loses to steven strange and he's like
okay strange you beat me you get to be
sorcerer supreme still but you got to
help me get my mom out of hell and uh
doctor strange was like let's do it
buddy let's and then they go to hell to
get his mom out uh and i it's like a
great team up uh but i i love that as a
motivator so that's the only reason i
don't want doom to be a kang i think
doom's a king i think doom's a king like
honestly
actually though a fun little little
piece just for like all the fans
watching at home a little inside inside
knowledge about how new rockstars works
is that um in order to get a job here
your mom has to
exactly and if she doesn't then
you're not getting a page we're all here
to try to get our moms out
we're all we're trying to get our moms
out of hand
and that's why eric was going so far
[Laughter]
it also says in our contract that we're
not supposed to talk about that causing
our contract so
[Laughter]
we'll have a talk with mephisto later
but yeah
let's uh let's vote on this like what do
you guys think about this thing yeah
vote on this theory rogus bogus or oh
i think it's rogue
ultra rovers rogues i'm in this yes i
want this i want doom to be a kang i
want kang to be a doom i want
[Laughter]
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
brandon your hang up but like yeah maybe
it's that he's lived a life and for what
he knows and his maybe his mom
maybe maybe it could be his adoptive mom
or you know i think there's ways i like
secret i like him being a secret still
have yeah if it's a secret cam where he
doesn't know
then that he's a kang somehow then i
think he could still have his own
original story and it could still tie
into what they're doing so yeah i love
it too i dig it i dig it i dig it nice
job random
very smart smart smart
theory but now it is time for our real
question are you guys ready for this one
are you just ready for this
i don't know
uh all right here we go ready for this
i'm a child of the 90s all right here we
go there have been a lot of rumors this
week about taran anderton meeting with
marvel studios to potentially take on
the role of one logan wolverine man
taren has denied these rumors and really
he's too safe of a pick for wolverine so
let's go rogue give me your rogues
choice of an actor to take on the role
of wolverine in the mcu
[Music]
who's the hairiest guy i know
[Music]
i forget his name but uh yeah ted
right boy can't do it right right you
can't wait
brett goldstein thank you yes
and with that gruff kind of low oh he
would have been a great although he
would yeah yeah and he looked super
ripped i don't know if that's cg muscles
or
[Music]
his end credits but he was pretty ripped
almost wolverine level ripped so that's
true brett goldstein i don't know if
that counts since he's already playing
someone else but hey why not multiverse
and he's a tough mofo yeah
if they do like
a variant of wolverine for the
multiverse that you could he could play
two roles why not no one would care um
yeah what do you guys think okay you
guys i've clicked on an article from may
2013 called hollywood's hairy house and
i'm going to flip through for some
inspiration please wait are you using
your private browser make sure you use
it
[Laughter]
no i'm using the public new rockstars
let's see oh hugh jackman's already on
the list so harry kane standing here
ashton kutcher's on the list actually is
not that hairy
mark ruffalo not that a little bit hairy
lenny kravitz ah well he's got he's he
has beautiful hair i would say but i
wouldn't
well they they all have chests here
we've seen their chest hair
like
every day
box catcher this list this list is from
2013 that i'm looking at and all of
these men are already
faced
with
the market yo 2013 was like the height
of mars
i mean like
avengers 1 just
yeah that makes sense um
oh my god
okay well that means it didn't work um
and i want like you know they have never
really captured the short rotundness of
wolverine that that we really need and i
want to like bring back an older
wolverine you know let's get uh danny
devito in there as wolverine
i was just going to say charlie day as a
joke but dave devito is hilarious
charlie would be a good
but when he's on cocaine
he could be cyclops
[Music]
that would be hilarious
these are all great yes um great uh
answers but i think i'm gonna have to
give it to mr tom for uh that really
rogue suggestion of recasting the newly
minted hercules as wolverines
yeah
yeah two rolls
um what's his face from the boys
wolverine really great um my blankie on
his name um
i got
oh my god
that is it for um episode of rogue
theory thank you to our wonderful
amazing guest whitney van lenningham tom
michelson and off-screen producer
brandon support all of them follow them
on twitter and everything that they do
and support our channel by checking out
all of our amazing merch options over at
new rockstarsmerch.com and if you got
thoughts on some of our rogue theories
you can share them on our discord if
you're over 18 just click the link for
the new rockstars discord server in the
description and join the conversation
you can follow me at mastertainment you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
really fun theories you follow new
rockstars on all our social platforms
and make sure you hit that bell when you
subscribe here on youtube thank you guys
for watching we love you guys so much
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
do
[Music]